what do you feel about
another attack another painful thing I
imagine super painful is Balenciaga
pulling um
uh
you had a really close relationship and
friendship with their uh creative
director
like how do you feel about all of it
I told you I sang the song I'll sing
another song from one of my mentors
future I never feel pain
I haven't felt too much pain
like there was a day where I was headed
to Nashville to meet with George farmer
who was the CEO of parla the the day
when we made the announcement
at that same day
uh Balenciaga
uh was taking my imagery off of their
site
and uh the drink Champs was being taken
down
and I said this is the happiest day of
my life
I love cutting the grass low
people wasn't really with you they was
part-time people switch up when it's
wartime I'd rather have people who are
really with me and not people who are
just trying to use me listen as a friend
that somebody cares for you you have to
be really careful by the People by all
people always the people that are going
to be try to be close to you now you
don't know if you can trust them anymore
they are with the Blissey I want I have
more to say about it though yeah
let's do this
dimna will still work
for yay someday and this is just
speeding the process up
have you talked can you share if you've
talked yes I'll I talked to dimna this
is like we're Kendrick Spirits none of
this can keep us away from each other I
brought dimna to Gap to be able to bring
the best product in the world at that
time I wanted to go under a hundred
dollars now I'm like okay we're gonna go
20 a product uh I brought dimna in
to engineer that's why I said engineer
by Balenciaga easy guy I'm engineered by
Balenciaga to engineer the best product
for the people the people that
that they say are at the bottom of the
Maslow hierarchy of need
chart they're at the bottom of the
pyramid right so
Gap didn't want that Balenciaga didn't
want that
our agendas were not aligned I was
brought in
to the gap for political reasons and
influence like a Virgil like a George
Floyd
when popular celebrities are brought
into Fortune 500 companies is not to
raise the stock it's to strengthen the
position and influence
and is definitely not to be out here
letting a [ __ ] think he's Steve Jobs
yeah there's people like that
but you as a great man and visionary
your job
is to understand that game and be one
step ahead
well that's why I'm telling them that
relationship you know some relationships
only last for a summer
yeah you know some last for a year the
relationship ran its course
you know
in that relationship I invested a lot of
my social capital and actual Capital
that I spent somewhere between five to
ten million dollars personally on
Balenciaga how much money do you think
Balenciaga had paid me in the past two
years
just take a really wild guess a really
wow less than that
just take a super wild one
just go to your the furthest extent of
your imagination
1.2 million
lower
five hundred thousand lower
zero zero all right and actually two
weeks ago I paid at a Saints account
eight hundred and sixty two thousand
dollars not in close for me from
Balenciaga from the store in royalties
to Balenciaga where the deal had been
engineered where I was coming out of my
pocket so I paid last year I paid demna
three million dollars
to
uh to design The Collection right and we
got it out of the Gap marketing fund and
he was going to deliver 160 skus or 120
skus 100 skus are separate items of
clothing uh so
uh styles of clothing
so he ended up delivering about 60.
well I feel like we're on the People's
Court because we actually are right in
the court of public opinion
uh so he delivered about 60. there were
all kinds of people that were working
part of the reason why I had to get
dimna like I didn't want to have to I
wanted to compete with him I don't want
to have to like get him you know when I
made stronger I did it to compete with
Timberland and and Justin Timberlake
because my fiance at that time like
Justin Timberlake just a little bit too
much so I made it to compete and then we
had the song out it's number one on
Apple it's blowing up I play it in a
club and it sounds muddy it doesn't
sound the way
Sexy Back sounded in the club so I go to
Pharrell
Williams to to do the drums and it
doesn't it sounds like a different
record I know it can't be a different
record because I'm like I'm gonna swap
it out on radio right then I go to Swiss
beats it sounds like a different record
I go to Timberland the person who did
sexy back
and he did he did it
in five minutes and then spent the rest
of the hour talking about how nobody
could have done it except for him
running around the studio I'm the best
no what could it that's why he had to go
to me had to go to the king well he had
a point right he had a point right so
what makes us some money is it the beat
it was in the drums it was something
that Timberland had in those drums like
now watch this
I said I'm going Defcon 3 right and the
actual I spelled it wrong I have a
tendency to do that I'm not quite John
Legend tight sweater level spelling B
level so I feel a parallel to me going
to Timberland
to when I said hey you as an engineer I
need to work with you as an engineer
that is Jewish
to look at these contracts and what my
people
not just black people let's say artists
are dealing with in our contracts these
contracts need to be fixed everyone
could be so mad at the messenger right
yay you said it the wrong way you're
offensive you're like Hitler now because
you said it you said this out loud but
it does not you're you weren't getting
enough sleep all this [ __ ] does not
negate the fact
that we do have Houston we have a
problem
yeah but we it's just the music industry
like there's a lot of hate that was
created by just saying that you know but
you're saying what is just is everything
to me right yeah yeah one one person
everything to me right and for George
Bush winning an election was everything
and then when you said George Bush
doesn't care about black people that you
woke him up you woke the people up to
the fact that he was narrowly being
selfish you are there's a sense to which
you're being corrupted by your own
greatness that you're focusing too much
on the industry that you've made great
that you've Rose to the very top one of
the richest artists in history one of
the greatest designers I'm not I am the
richest artist in history
probably the richest artist in history
yeah they say the funny thing is they're
like oh riches black person's like oh
also richest actor richest musician
richest fashion designer like is a bunch
of riches in that one yeah I'm saying
it's like richer than Ralph Lauren like
like richer than Amani like richest like
of that but still low because where do
you put that you know like on the totem
because I don't even want to uh man's
bank account isn't everything
I would say you and I are equal
in a certain deep sense
no matter what the bank account says
so I wanted to give you some theme music
for uh for your mom a little money let
me give you the Timberland version
thank you
okay so the other thing about like say
like Balenciaga is
demna will work with yay someday and
for Cedric and for Francois Pino and
Selma's is a beautiful human being
five years from now
you'll hear and know the name yay and no
things that we did
and
Balenciaga is not going to make it onto
your questions
would you what would you as a Gambling
Man Would you bet on that I will bet on
that I can see it in your eyes so so it
was sad it was actually a sad day for me
not for me but more for Balenciaga
I just when I when I heard that I was
just like
oh shame